[Musique]
et aujourd'hui j'accueille le
porte-parole du parti socialiste député
des landes bonjour boris vallot bonjour
à vous alors nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un entretien en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
est représenté aujourd'hui par stéphane
bern et du journal ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour et on va commencer
cette interview par évoquer les
violences policières et la manifestation
d'hier à paris de 20000 personnes contre
les violences policières également en
hommage au jeune adama traoré mort en
2016 après une interpellation de la
gendarmerie
est-ce que compte tenu du contexte
américain et des manifestations aux
états unis ce mouvement américain peut
s'étendre à la france toujours difficile
de spéculer mais l'interpellation des
autorités politiques françaises sur la
question des violences policières
les doctrines de maintien de l'ordre
elles sont indépendantes de ce qui se
passe aux etats unis est évidemment les
comparaisons sont toujours hasardeuse
mais le fait qu'ils aient 20000
personnes hier dit quelque chose
ça vous a surpris oui ça m'a surpris
c'est beaucoup de monde compte tenu des
circonstances
c'est une vraie interpellations et qu'il
faut écouter en sortant des dilemmes
appauvri du stylet ce qu'il faut aimer
ou détester la police croit que le sujet
n'est pas là le racisme ils étouffent
partout
la police elle doit être exemplaire
partout et la france doit être un modèle
avec une police républicaine d'une
certaine manière au fond l'antithèse de
la police américaine tels que elle est
dénoncée aujourd'hui et ça veut dire
regardez les choses sans fard et les
interpellations sur ses plaquages au sol
sur l'utilisation d'un certain nombre
d'armes et bien nous aurions tort de ne
pas les entend pas ce que un fait divers
quand ils se multiplient çà devient un
fait social et donc je crois qu'il faut
regarder ça et et et mesurer à la fois
ce que vivent un certain nombre de
personnes non tendance un certain nombre
de quartiers ce que sont les pratiques
policières façon dont ils exercent aussi
leur mission parce que certains d'entre
eux aussi ont des craintes
et puis le désir de bien faire en tout
cas voilà je crois que je vous dis
le combat contre le racisme c'est un
combat qu'est jamais jamais achevée
l'exemplarité de la police c'est une
exigence républicaine et démocratique
tous les états de droit et la france
doit être une certaine manière
exemplaire est un exemple en cette
matière là ça a du sens de faire un
parallèle entre les situations
américaines et françaises en matière de
police et de maintien de l'ordre
je connais pas suffisamment les états
unis mais je dis que les évidemment les
comparaisons seront toujours hasardeuse
toujours incomplètes parfois insuffisant
d'autrefois excessive
ce que j'observe aux états unis laissent
totalement pantois parce qu'il ya
quelque chose de systémique après des
décennies de l'histoire de lutte pour
les droits civils n'est pas le cas en
france
et non ce qui n'est pas le cas en france
quand on sait depuis vos avocats sur un
sacré veinard a dit oui on l'a
interpellé fait c'est un problème de
technique aussi
il ya des choses qui à mon avis des
pratiques et qui n'ont pas leur place
lesquels par exemple le placage ventrale
une tout le monde ne le dit moi je suis
prêt que la mort de cédric souvient
alors d'une interprète
on mesure bien que cette pratique elle a
des conséquences et des sujets de
formation des sujets de doctrine
il ya des sujets d'armement qui les
sujets de déontologie et puis il ya moi
je crois à la police républicaine je
crois qu'elle est demandée par tous les
citoyens et les policiers eux mêmes sont
des citoyens donc sortons didier
m'appauvrir regardons les difficultés là
où elles existent avec des réalités
objectives et qui sont ressenties par
beaucoup dans leur chair mais c'est pas
et pas matière à polémique il ya matière
à travailler quand le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner affirme
que la police protège de tout y compris
du racisme c'est une réalité c'est une
vérité selon vous les gars je crois
qu'ils aient des d'efforts
supplémentaires qu'il faut faire il
s'agit pas de faire le procès de tel ou
tel s'agit de dire que le racisme
étouffe partout et que c'est un combat
jamais achevée que c'est celui de tous
les responsables politiques c'est celui
aussi de la police n'y a pas de place
nulle part je pense pour l'impunité
maurice val on a parlé des élections
municipales puisque ça y est les
candidats au second tour ont déposé leur
liste définitive pour le scrutin du 28
juin les alliances locales se sont créés
et dans plusieurs grandes villes
il y à des alliances entre la république
en marche et les
public 1 notamment à bordeaux à lyon à
clermont ferrand à strasbourg est ce que
ces alliances et les rues mlr elle
clarifie le paysage politique a pour
ceux qui avaient besoin d'une clarté
supplémentaires sur ce qu'était la
république en marche
peut-être pour beaucoup d'autres qui ont
vu depuis trois ans ce qu'était la
politique du gouvernement je crois que
au fond cela tombe sous le sens oui
c'est un gouvernement qui fait une
politique de droite et qui a vocation au
plan local à s'allier avec la droite
avec parfois comme seul dessin c'est
quand même finalement assez désolant est
décevant de battre la gauche et les
écologistes qui ont fait dans beaucoup
de villes bloc pour ce second tour
bon voilà et alors après évidemment il
ya des choses qui sont tout à fait
savoureuse
ce qui est absolument inadmissible à
lyon devient finalement le modèle à
bordeaux à strasbourg ou dans les villes
que vous avez cités donc le parti la
république en marche au niveau national
est un peu dépassé par ses alliances je
crois que c'est dans son essence même
avoir ce d'avoir brouillé les identités
politiques
on s'est demandé où il était et puis
finalement une fois que les cubes ce
disciple on voit que la république en
marche fait le choix des alliances avec
la droite alors à gauche la gauche et
les écologistes vous venez de le dire
font bloc dans certaines villes mais pas
dans tout donc à paris un an tout à
rennes ça se passe très bien les ans les
alliances parti socialiste europe
écologie les verts par contre ça n'a pas
fonctionné à lille à dijon strasbourg
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se passe écoutez
il ya évidemment toujours des
circonstances locales qui qui pèse moi
ce que je veux dire parce que c'est
important
donc prendre la mesure le fait important
le fait majeur pour ce second tour
c'est que s'est constitué pratiquement
partout en france
un bloc social et écologisme c'est
important ça répond à une aspiration des
françaises et des français et j'espère
ça préfigure une alternative à ce tête à
tête entre les libéraux et les
nationalistes donc c'est tout à fait
important en tout cas ce que je peux
dire le travail qui a été accompli au
niveau national et au niveau local c'est
que le parti socialiste a fait ses
meilleurs efforts pour rendre ces
alliances possibles
il ya des endroits où ça n'a pas été
possible qu'est ce que les écologistes
qui sont qui à un moment il ya un mois
je veux pas distribuer des bons et des
mauvais points
ça ne s'est pas fait il y as second tour
les électeurs trancheront
et puis je retiens je le dis ce qui est
le fait majeur le fait politique majeur
de ce second tour c'est qu'il ya un bloc
ce bloc est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
en position de faire une espèce de grand
chelem sur l'axé paris lyon marseille
lille paris lyon marseille je l'espère
évidemment que je l'espère je veux
croire que ce bloc non seulement
conservera ses positions mais aura des
conquêtes
voilà mais évidemment il ya un second
tour et il faut qu'il se déroule mais
c'est important parce que ça constitue
aussi une alternative à ce que
j'écrivais tout à l'heure un mot sur la
poussée écologiste lors de ce scrutin
municipal qui est une revendication des
français et ce qu'il ne faut pas pour le
parti socialiste donner plus de place
dans la gouvernance locale aux
écologistes c'est ce qu'a refusé martine
aubry c'est ce qu'a également refusé
catherine trautmann dans son alliance à
strasbourg qui a échoué avec la
candidate écologiste de strass demi j'ai
bien compris votre question mais je vous
répondrais de la même manière qu'est ce
qu'on pensait de la poussée que la
science dans beaucoup d'endroits et bien
ce seront des gouvernances qui seront
des gouvernants se partager et et tant
mieux
la poussée écologiste a poussé de la
question écologique qui est
incontournable majeur la finitude du
monde personne ne peut la contester
elle ébranle évidemment tous les cadres
connu notre modèle de développement
entre façon de produire de consommer de
se déplacer d'inviter tout ça a des
conséquences immédiates des conséquences
de moyen terme et
les français s'en préoccuper et au parti
socialiste le choix aussi de la
constitution de ce blog c'est le fait de
mettre la question écologique et la
question sociale au premier rang des
réponses que les français attendent
l'épidémie de copies de 19 à changer
beaucoup de choses on est en train de
changer beaucoup de choses y compris la
façon de faire campagne parce qu'il va
falloir faire campagne pour ce deuxième
tour mais sans contact sans aller sur
les marchés sans meeting
est-ce que comment comment est ce que
vous voyez les choses comment ça va se
passer c'est possible mais de faire
campagne
avoir une campagne municipale numérique
aujourd'hui oui campagne numérique
elle existe déjà elle se déploie on a
bien vu d'ailleurs la façon dont on a
travaillé depuis deux mois deux mois et
demi ça a été très dématérialisée très
intermédié par les webcams etc
bien sûr c'est inconfortable c'est
inconfortable parce que rien ne remplace
le contact direct
rien ne remplace les moments
d'interpellation de confrontation
évidemment de fraternité et de et de
communion dans dance et c'est ce qui est
ce que vous redoutez une forte
abstention pour ce deuxième tour elle
est évidemment à craindre
il est évidemment à craindre parce que
il s'est passé beaucoup de temps entre
le premier et le second tour
mais ce que je crois que les français ça
parce qu'ils l'ont vu au quotidien c'est
que le maire c'est l'échelon de
proximité de la démocratie du quotidien
les maires ont été très mobilisés ceux
qui ont été prolongées ont été très
mobilisés dans la gestion de la crise de
la crise du duduk ovide 19 voit bien que
c'est un échelon important et qu'il faut
lui donner cette légitimité démocratique
concernant le scrutin du 28 juin le
sénat a voté en faveur d'une proposition
de loi qui a autorisé au final le vote
par correspondance est ce que vous
voterez pour ce vote par correspondance
oui en effet je crois que on est à un
moment où il faut précisément parce
qu'elle est question potentiellement de
participation se donner tous les moyens
d'un scrutin avec il ya le plus de monde
possible qu'ils se rendent aux urnes par
tous moyens y compris par le vote par
correspondance et c'est notamment mon
collègue sénateur eric kerrouche
sénateurs des lords qui en a fait la
proposition
sortons de ces élections municipales
pour aller au niveau national au niveau
politique vous avez signé il ya quelques
semaines une tribune pour le
semblement des forces de gauche et
écologistes est ce que ces élections
municipales justement peuvent encourager
une union de la gauche et des verts au
niveau national en vue de 2022
oui je crois que c'est une aspiration de
beaucoup de françaises et de français
c'est une responsabilité pour beaucoup
de responsables politiques importants de
la tautologie
c'est un chantier auquel beaucoup
s'attelle et qui je crois prospère il y
à la nécessité d'un travail de fond on
l'accomplît les uns et les autres dans
les fonctions qui sont qui sont les
nôtres à l'assemblée dans les
collectivités locales
et puis en discussion entre entre les
responsables et partis politiques est ce
qu'un écologiste pourrait emmener cette
union de la gauche côté on verra vous
savez dans le moment où nous sommes il
faut se garder de vous avez deux
positions définitives
je ne sais pas qui conduira quoi je
pense qu'on a la nécessité pour
constituer une alternative pour que la
question écologique et sociale deux
questions qui sont gérées les deux
piliers structurante de la vie politique
et de l'action publique dans les
prochaines années
et bien soit une offre pour les français
au moment des scrutins à venir
enfin qu'il ya une dynamique qui nous
volonté de retrouver en tout cas une
dynamique à gauche sauf que c'est une
gauche qui essaie de se reconstruire
sans les insoumis qu'est-ce-qui pourquoi
qui vous en voulez pas où ils veulent
pas venir ou est-ce que vous en êtes du
dialogue avec le hot et la porte est
toujours ouverte
donc c'est ce qui va se passer en plus
est ce qu'on peut vraiment les insoumis
il ya des tribunes il ya des discussions
qui se noue avec un certain nombre de
membres aussi de la france insoumise
bon moi je sais c'est compliqué par
exemple c'est drôle et c'est qu'au
niveau des municipales le cas de
toulouse par exemple oui il ya d'autres
endroits où il ya d'autres endroits que
ça c'est fait il ya d'autres endroits où
ça c'est fait donc moi je crois que les
choses ne sont jamais définitive et je
pense que nous avons encore évolué avons
en partage cette conscience qu'on peut
pas laisser les français dans une
alternative qui est une alternative dont
on a vu depuis trois ans qu'elle est une
impasse boris vallée on va évoquer
l'actualité parlementaire j'appelle que
vous êtes député des landes une
actualité parlementaire forcément
marqué par la crise sanitaire et on a
appris hier que le gouvernement
envisageait de prolonger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui va actuellement
jusqu'au 10 juillet une prorogation
jusqu'en septembre
est-ce que vous voterez pour cette
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire non et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement nous
a assez précisément indiqué que nous
allions devoir apprendre à vivre avec le
co vide et que au fond l'état normal de
notre vie quotidienne serait avec la
menace de ce virus d'où le maintien d'un
certain nombre de gestes barrières de
précaution sanitaire et que dès lors on
ne peut pas régler une situation qui
devient la situation ordinaire par des
mesures extraordinaires et donc dès lors
qu'elles ne se justifie pas eh bien je
crois qu'il n'y a pas nécessité de les
prolonger
voilà très clairement les choses dit et
puis par ailleurs je pense que dans le
moment que nous vivons nous avons besoin
d'éviter d'ajouter des exceptions aux
lois d'exception on a besoin d'une
vitalité de la vie démocratique et
pendant deux mois deux mois et demi j'en
ai été le témoin le parlement a mal
fonctionné je veux pas dire qu'il
fonctionne bien par ailleurs et en temps
normal on a un vrai sujet de réformes
institutionnelles qui se posera à mon
avis et de vitalité démocratique sera
mon avis très vite mais pour répondre à
votre question je crois que à période
ordinaire droit commun vous faites
partie des parlementaires qui trouvent
que le gouvernement abuse des
ordonnances a manifestement oui oui
manifestement oui il y à beaucoup des
ordonnances qui auraient pu être traités
de manière différente on aurait pu
constituer une commission
haddock qui aurait siégé en continu à
l'assemblée nationale pour débattre de
ce qui est urgent on a vu qu'on a été
capable de le faire je crois que il ya
des ordonnances quand on donne des
délais de ratification d'un an qui
manifestement ne sont pas urgentes
on est aussi dans des peut-être senti
dans ce moment de lui contre le coleader
plan international on est aussi dans une
guerre de modèle politique et la
démocratie doit faire la démonstration
que fidèle à ses valeurs
elle est au fond une arme puissante dans
ces moments de crise concernant la
solidarité envers les soignants
l'assemblée nationale a adopté hier un
texte pour permettre le don de congé au
personnel soignant la gauche de
l'hémicycle a été très critique envers
ce texte c'est pourtant une bonne
initiative
écoutez moi je comprend à la fois
l'intention qui est louable
je comprends et beaucoup de français le
souhaitent que ils veulent manifester
leur solidarité et leur reconnaissance
mais ce que je crois primordial c'est de
répondre à la question que pose des
soignants c'est quels moyens pour
l'hôpital c'est pas une question qu'ils
ont posés l'occasion de la crise du coc
vide avant le coc vide
ils étaient en grève pour beaucoup
d'entre eux depuis 18 mois avec des
difficultés qui sont anciennes et
profondes jeudi anciennes pour ne pas
être dans l'esquivé et qui appelle des
réponses et nous allons formuler au
moment du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale des propositions
sur le financement sur la rémunération
sur les effectifs sur le nombre de
soignants au lit du malade sur la
question de la gouvernance de l'hôpital
et donc il faut répondre puisque le
ségur s'ouvre il faut répondre à la
question des moyens
c'est celle là et les soignants ne
demandent ni charité ni médaille
ils demandent à pouvoir bien soigné il
peut demander à pouvoir bien travailler
et puis pour eux mêmes ils demandent à
pouvoir bien vivre et les congés il
voudrait d'abord pouvoir prendre les
leurs en un mot boris val où est-ce que
vous avez téléchargé l'application stop
covit de traçage numérique pendant cette
crise sanitaire non non vous avez vous
est fermement opposée non je vous savez
comme en toute chose la question est de
savoir si ce que cela porte atteinte aux
libertés individuelles et proportionnée
à l'objectif recherché
et bien en l'occurrence je pense que le
bénéfice sanitaire n'est pas au
rendez-vous et que l'atteinte aux
libertés individuelles et est de ce
point de vue là trop important on va
évoquer maintenant la relance économique
et les mesures à prendre pour éviter la
casse sociale dans le pays à la sortie
de cette crise sanitaire le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire a validé hier le prêt pour le
constructeur automobile renault 2,5
milliards d'euros on rappelle que le
constructeur va supprimer 4600 postes en
france est ce que l'état était assez
ferme avec renault je crois que depuis
trois ans le gouvernement
l'état actionnaire à d'abord été
défaillant vis-à-vis de renault
moi je crois qu'il ya un problème de
tutelle de l'état actionnaire et qui
dans le moment carlos ghosn a laissé
l'entreprise flotter vaciller et donc il
appartient aujourd'hui d'être très ferme
à la fois sûr évidemment la défense de
renault et que la puissance publique met
de l'argent recapitalise accorde des
prêts moi j'y suis favorable mais il
doit y avoir non seulement des
contreparties en terme social
il doit y avoir des contreparties en
termes de responsabilité sur la chaîne
de valeur ça veut dire des
relocalisations il faut ramener de la
charge sur les usines françaises ramené
de la charge des pays lequel sont
fabriqués aujourd'hui les automobiles et
qui tourne à plein il faut aussi de
l'innovation
il faut également gelé dire préparer la
transition écologique et la ce risque ou
disons ces investissements ils doivent
être partagés par l'état vous parliez de
relocalisation ça veut dire interdire
certaines délocalisations de renault
notamment en turquie
écoutez ça veut dire relocaliser ça veut
dire que ce qui a été délocalisée sur
des chaînes de montage à l'étranger doit
revenir ici si on est sur un contre à un
pacte social entre la nation qui vient
en aide à renault et renault
eh bien il faut que évidemment il est
des exigences que les exigences des
engagements qui soit réciproque
au-delà du cas de renault et pour
relancer ou faire rebondir l'économie
vous avez un certain d'entreprises qui
commencent à parler de gel des salaires
ou d'une diminution de salaire quelle
qu'elles qu'elles quel regard vous
portez vous sur ce type de proposition
d'abord je veux dire que
il ya nécessité d'un plan de rebond
extrêmement rapide
là on parle de l'automne c'est trop
c'est trop tard il faudra élaborer dès
maintenant c'est tout de suite c'est
concomitamment avec le déconfinement
sanitaire parce que vous avez vu les
perspectives économiques du gouvernement
ça grave on était dans les derniers
projets de votre finances rectificative
dans une perspective de -8% maintenant
on est à -11%
c'est à dire que l'économie ne rebondira
pas en septembre comme le gouvernement
l'avait été escomptée mais plutôt en
décembre janvier certains chefs
d'entreprise par le même de février ou
de mars 2021 et entre temps il y aura eu
des dégâts économiques considérables des
libérables il faut des mesures lesquels
qu'est ce que vous préconisez d'abord il
faut la prolongation du chômage partiel
dans une forme nouvelle c'est dire qu'il
faut pouvoir négocier des accords de
réduction du temps de travail dans
l'entreprise avec les partenaires
sociaux sur la base desquels accordé un
chômage partiel bien indemnisés et la
possibilité d'un cumul avec un plan de
formation massive pour prendre un
certain nombre de tournant et pour
profiter de ces moments qui sont des
moments chauds mais pour dire que ce
soit des moments fort mais ça c'est la
première chose ensuite on voit bien
qu'ils aient besoin de soutiens
sectoriels plus dynamique je pense à la
question du bâtiment avec la rénovation
thermique du bâtiment qui est évidemment
un sujet non seulement écologique social
mais aussi économique on a besoin
s'agissant du tourisme d'une aide à la
demande parce qu'il va falloir aussi
solvabiliser des gens qui vont perdre
des revenus parce qu'ils vont perdre
leur emploi parce que le confinement
leur a fait perdre pendant deux mois en
moyenne plus de 400 euros de revenus il
ya aussi des caps une épargne de
précaution dont il va falloir se
préoccuper de savoir si elle revient
vers l'économie donc en soutenant la
consommation en soutenant
l'investissement privé public celui des
collectivités locales elles seront
évidemment en première ligne
voilà ce que je peux vous dire mais il
ya une urgence à faire parce que tout
retard toujours perdu accroît la facture
et la fracture est justement vous parlez
de factures comment en quelques mots ont
financé bien toute cette relance le
ministre des comptes publics gérald
darmanin a annoncé un déficit qui
pourrait s'élever à 220 milliards
d'euros le déficit de la sécurité
sociale à 52 millions
d'euros comment on finance on le finance
d'abord par la nette par une politique
monétaire qui doit être très favorables
à al haouz est aux dettes des états avec
une monétisation de cette dette la plus
la plus large possible ça me paraît
important et puis il va falloir se poser
la question des ressources et là où j'ai
un désaccord avec gérald darmanin c'est
que dans toutes les grandes situation de
crise on a mis les plus hauts
patrimoines à contribution et donc il va
falloir que cela participe à l'effort
national
et on ne peut pas j'allais dire refuser
le retour de li sf et bien deux côtés en
appeler aux minéraux milliardaire pour
qu'ils fassent des dons est une forme de
paradoxe qui n'est pas tenable
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous sur
ce plateau merci beaucoup
stéphane pour avoir mené avec moi cette
interview